hey 42 here feeling a German invasion in
1940 Alan Turing converted his assets
into silver ingots and buried them in
Buckinghamshire he spent the rest of his
life failing to find them welcome to RIF
in 2014 a single parking space in London
was sold for 400,000 pounds the Duke of
Wellington's horse Copenhagen died from
eating too many sponge cakes bath buns
and chocolate creams in 2013 nine babies
born in the UK were named cheese the
International Space Station travels at
five miles a second it's impossible to
get lost in a labyrinth
unlike mazes mud rooms have only one
possible route
Chewbacca's voice was created by
combining the sounds of a bear a walrus
a lion under-budget people eat less in
subdued lighting conditions president
george w bush was once a cheerleader
bananas have more trade regulations than
ak-47s taking a photo something reduces
your ability to remember it in parts of
western china it is customary to put
salt into your tea instead of sugar the
Great Pyramid of Giza was built by a
hundred thousand people working ten
hours a day for 20 years after getting
out of the bath the ancient Greeks
covered themselves with olive oil each
day 22 percent of people skip lunch it
would take 225 million years to walk a
light-year thanks for the view subscribe
for more thoughty2